larry
as a as a parent we know how to
create urgency with our kids as a boss
you know how to create urgency with the
folks who
you know report to you as a ceo
founder you know you know how to drive
an organization you're the president of
a
university with you know roughly 1450
students from 47 states including dc and
foreign countries
we know how to create urgency right
there are ways to create urgency
sometimes i wonder if the political
parties
are using fear tactics to create
urgency for people to vote but it's not
really the end of the world let me
explain you know it's
oh you guys if we don't get trump back
in let me tell you what's going to
happen it's the end of the war if we
don't get
trump out if we're going to be into the
world that's
i think there's it's so much of that
from both sides it's the end of the
world tactic to create urgency to want
to go out there and vote
but i know a lot of people that has
created the kind of anxiety that people
are
losing their minds they're thinking the
end of the world is really coming to
america
and so as as as
as effective a strategy that maybe to
create urgency
i also think it's increased anxiety and
panic into
families at the highest level today so
to to either reassure or validate the
point
you do you think there is a real
real sense of urgency of what could
potentially happen to america
or are the documents that our founders
wrote
that we have together in our court
system are we still going to be
protected
long term by that
well you know every we have to save
the country the country's in trouble
having said that
we should be cultivating respect for our
fellow citizens
and we should be cultivating reason
and not force because when you start
using force then you get the civil war
and that's a god-awful mess
uh so yeah sure and and uh
we should look to compromise everywhere
we can
uh these uh sweeping things that they
propose to do those are not compromises
and those should be resisted but they
should be resisted with the argument
you know i i issued a massive call for
action
at three receptions in arkansas and
texas this week
and the call for action was here's a
list of books you should read and then
you should talk to your neighbors about
them
that's the kind of thing that can get us
out of this mess
so so here's here's the part i want you
to know from my end
larry i'm not worried if it is a real
urgent
matter that we may lose the country and
i'm comfortable
it being just a marketing tactic i'm
both either way i'm just trying to see
from your standpoint
which one is it more are we really
you're somebody that
is well read this is your world it's
like talking to a doc if i go have a
meeting with a doctor i'm going to ask
the question from the doctor
i just had a physical so i got my score
back on triglycerides i got my
cholesterol score back
and i use that hour to ask every single
possible question i can about the body
that i have to see what i can get
i have you right now you've been in this
world for a while is it really that
urgent and that scary
or this too shall pass
uh well it will surely pass
all human things pass away but the way
you analyze it
you know so aristotelian political
science the first political science
here's how it works you think about the
causes
of things in aristotle everything has
four
causes it's made out of something that's
the
material cause somebody made it that's
the efficient cause
it looks like something that's the
formal cause
and it seeks something or loves
something
that's the final cost the most important
or the last two
in america the final cause of america is
the declaration of independence and it's
principle that we are created equal and
endowed by our created with rights
that's that's what we love we americans
that's what brought you and your family
to this country
and 150 years before what brought my
family to this country
so the formal cause
what the people of america when they act
together look like
is they look like the structure of the
constitution
the executive branch the congress and
the courts
and so if you have a debate going on
and this is the third time this has
happened in american history
the first is the revolution and the
second is the civil war
if you have a debate going on about the
meaning of that final cause
there's a sharp difference of opinion
about what equality constitutes
the equality that you came to this
country for was
we're going to start out as nobody's as
we are likely nobody's where we are
right now because it's
turned into a tyranny but here's a place
where nobodies
get a chance they gotta go
and so that's your equality right and
it'll come out different according to
different people the other quality is
if somebody is higher than somebody else
that has to be
discrimination and the government exists
to even that out
and so that's a very fundamental debate
it can't be both those things
it's either one or the other well and
then the formal right
so this pack in the court you know we
have created
a you know the worst no no in the
is a violation of the constitution and
the founders was to delegate the
legislative power uh the first three
articles you know the first is about the
legislature and the second is about the
executive and the thirds about
the judges they all begin with
the blank power shall be vested in
so the executive power in a president
the judicial power in a supreme court in
the lower courts
only the first one says all the
legislative power
that word all only occurs there and if
you read john locke you'll see there's a
whole
chapter about the vice of delegating the
legislative power because if you do that
there can be a lot more laws you know
the congress the united states
makes and the president signs about 150
to 200 laws a year
and that's the number that it's made for
250 years
and why it works the same way it's
cumbersome it takes a while
and so now they delegated that out right
and you know in the last year of obama i
happen to know
they added 80 000 pages of regulations
to the federal register
few of those were made by the congress
and then the question is
who made them well you got to look it up
right because there's 150 agencies or so
by the way there's a there's been every
little while there's an outbreak of
argument about exactly how many
administrative agencies there are the
answer is they're too many to count
precisely and uh and so
yeah we're we've built a great engine
and uh it's bigger than we are or
threatening to become so
and so my point is we should be
concerned about that
and we should think that through right
it it it's not enough
we do need a very high level of
statesmanship
the reason we got out of the civil war
is that man sitting back there over your
right shoulder right he was nobody
you know hardly anybody in history like
him
well we need that standard now we need
somebody who's
eloquent who has a deep understanding
who can explain beautifully and who's
courageous
and you know donald trump is some of
those things but
you know it would be it's it's almost
like a miracle
when you get somebody as good as that
you know winston churchill was like that
he was just an awesome human being
and he changed things because of that
and he could because and and he did it
with his mouth
you know he just uh people heard what he
said
and it was more powerful than swords
although it put a lot of swords into
motion
larry why do you think men like that are
hated
well i mean churchill was hated if you
read his books
and and i'm a churchill guy myself as
well but why are people like that
leaders like that hated
well you know first of all they do a lot
you know they're consequential and uh
at the biggest scale people like that
make decisions
that help or harm very large numbers of
people
the good ones uh they don't intend to
harm anybody
except as an act of justice if
somebody's done wrong
but you know like uh
here's an example here's what happens
when you're a statesman
uh churchill forecast the horrors of
modern war
he's a very brave soldier he wrote three
best belt selling books about his
war experiences before he was 26 years
old
and in 1901 he forecast the dead
dreadful cost
of the first world war only one who did
and then he tried to avoid that war and
then when they got in that war
he tried to mitigate its cost in life
especially
he said we're a free country we don't
send you know
a big percentage of our young men to
death
in a four-year period so he had two
plans
and one was uh he he started the
experiments that involved that invented
the tank
he's the one who thought it up it's
called tank
because he was in the admiralty he was
the head of the navy and he got a naval
engineer to start working on it
and the code name was watership's tanks
he was trying to spare life well then
the other thing was to go around
and since the trenches went from the
alps to the sea
you sort of had to go around the count
of the continent and so he went down to
the
straits of the dardanelles and tried to
force them with the navy
and get through you know in turkey which
was in league with germany in that war
was in the way well it didn't work
and the thing is this effort of his to
save
lives ended up costing
a lot of lives and those people you know
whose family members died
they didn't know what his motive was if
it had worked it would have saved
millions of lives
and it didn't work and you know he
learned a lot of lessons
from that he thought maybe while he
accepted responsibility for this part
he actually didn't think up that
particular way of going about this
cotton wide flanking maneuver he wanted
to go north
but he adopted it and when it met
trouble everybody else sort of
drifted away and they left him holding
the bag
uh and so he learned from that
what he learned was don't take
responsibility for something you don't
have the authority to accomplish
so that means by the way that tens of
thousands of people
on the galilee peninsula many of them
from australia and new zealand
died because that that effort went wrong
and churchill's part in it was that if
he had seen
that they were going to blame him for
this and he still didn't have the power
to make it happen
he might have stopped it and
in the second world war he learned he
set things up very differently from that
so the point is states the statesmen
have consequences
and sometimes people are harmed whatever
they do and the innocent people too
and then of course there are the
partisans on the other side you know
i mean until uh sometime in september
1940 but reoccurring through the war
they were leading people in the british
government and the british aristocracy
who were in touch with hitler
trying to work out a piece and thought
that britain on a
ought to side with hitler and then you
know the communists in
in britain uh they uh
agitated against the war uh
well uh in the beginning because in the
in the beginning of the war
the soviet union was in league with nazi
germany
and so the daily worker and the
communist rags in britain
they agitated against getting in the war
and then the minute hitler attacked
stalin then they wanted to get in they
were all for it right and so
partisanship explains a lot too and the
challenge
and it's the challenge for every citizen
too is to
do the work think as hard as you can
say your prayers try to place yourself
in the right
and try to place yourself in the right
in a way that harms the fewest people
and helps the most and uh so that's the
spirit
and that's you know that spirit is
strained right now
in the country because it's hyper
partisan
i agree it is hyper partisan you know
you said something earlier
thank you for explaining that regarding
why uh folks like churchill are hated at
the level that they are and i know you
kind of said
we need a lincoln and we need a uh trump
has some of that
you know where they have similar uh
methods of facing opposition and power
who is the closest thing to lincoln that
we have right now are you seeing anybody
outside of trump i'm talking about the
future
who is somebody you're looking at right
now that could be a future lincoln
well i have hopes for some of the young
ones who i'm an old man now and so i
know a lot of people
and uh you know tom cotton as senators
friend of mine we're both from arkansas
it means we're cousins
um he uh you know mike pence is a heck
of a guy
do they have that level of talent
well we'll see right you know i
tom cotton is a personal friend of mine
i've known him a long time a long time
before he got in politics
and uh you know i i believe by the way
that clarence thomas
is one of the greatest americans in
history i think he's the greatest member
of the court
in our time and so he he's not
he's not a political man he's a legal
slash political man
but i think he has the qualities in
spades i mean it's just awesome
so anyway there's some greatness but is
there that level of greatness that's
kind of once in a hundred years kind of
thing
i agree i agree i i think that's why
when sometimes people say we need a
reagan we need a lincoln we needed this
i think it sometimes puts the pressure
on the party because everybody's sitting
there saying well you know no one can
compare to reagan's humor and wit no one
can compare to
you know what lincoln had to do when he
went against and it kind of uh uh
uh uh sometimes scares some people off
to say well maybe i'm not that good
enough to go there by the way didn't
claim
thomas wasn't he a faculty faculty of uh
uh
hillsdale i thought he was faculty right
yeah
well i you know i just was fortunate to
meet him
before he became famous and before he
became famous
i i began to think that he's one of the
greatest people i'd ever seen
and then he got on the court and you
know he's just he's a very magnificent
man magnanimous man
so uh i went to see him one time
and uh you know i don't go to see him
very often because i don't feel like god
to take his time but he usually
chastises me for not
but i said you know justice this morning
i said i've done some work
and i have to talk to you about
something and i'm going to take 30
minutes
and i apologize in advance you won't
like it
and he said what do you want to talk
about larry and i said i want to talk
about your greatness
he said i don't want to talk about that
and i said see i told you
i'm going to read you some things that
you've written
and some things that john marshall wrote
and some things that some of your
contemporaries wrote and you will see
that you are a recovery of something
amazing
and i read it to him and he he actually
said
larry you know you and your friends
helped me learn how to do that and i
said sir
we do not know how to do that we are not
judges
you have done that thank god for it
well i just think he's awesome and i
don't mind saying so and he doesn't like
me saying
so he he he comes across as i've never
met him he comes across i've watched a
lot of his uh on how he takes his
approach
he seems like a very strong character
type of a leader
and uh yeah and it's and it's good to
see you saying that about him